passez à l'article 4 avec l'amendement
21 rectifié bis monsieur de lège pardon
madame de la gontrie
merci monsieur le président de me donner
la parole pour un rappel au règlement
portant sur l'organisation de nos débats
hier le sénat a décidé de supprimer
l'article l'article avait pour objet
essentiel d'étendre l'accès à la pma aux
couples de femmes et potentiellement aux
femmes seules
certes articles ayant été supprimée
force est de s'interroger sur la
pertinence de l'examen de l'article 4
car l'article 4 portes sur les modes de
filiation qui avaient été construits
justement pour permettre à l'enfant né
dans ces circonstances de d'avoir une
filiation établie donc cet article 1
dont le sort je dois vous le confier
m'est assez obscur à l'heure où je
m'exprime puisqu'il doit faire l'objet
d'une deuxième délibération dont je n'ai
pas extrêmement bien compris qu'elle
serait le contour
toujours est il que se positionnèrent
sur un article 4 qui organise le système
de la filiation justifiée par un article
1 qui n'existe plus et qui existera
peut-être tout ça en les choses quand
même extrêmement complexe alors je suis
bien que président karoutchi vous disiez
dans assez bon nous ne sommes pas le
conseil d'état mais quand même il ya de
la marge
donc je n'en ai pas le pouvoir mais je
demande à la commission et ou au
gouvernement de demander la réserve de
cet article afin que nous l'examinions
après que le sort définitif de l'article
20 étaient étrangers
acte et donnez votre appel règlement la
parole est à monsieur le garde des
sceaux monsieur le président monsieur
président de la commission spéciale même
le rapporteur mais l'homme est sénatrice
messieurs les sénateurs avant de
commencer l'examen de l'article 4 je
souhaiterais revenir sur la non-adoption
de l'article 1er cet article a été
renvoyé en commission spéciale qui
décidera s'il ya lieu ou non dont le
faire revoter avant la fin de l'examen
du texte
les débats qui vont avoir lieu sur la
filiation en cas de pma doivent donc se
dérouler en toute connaissance de cause
des choix à venir du sénat ceci dans un
souci de clarté et de sincérité des
débats parlementaires souhaitent donc
vous indiquer que si l'article 1er en
venait à ne pas être réintégré dans le
projet de loi le gouvernement
demanderait alors qu'il y est une
nouvelle délibération sur l'article 4 à
des fins de coordination
bon un peu d'ordre
pardon mais chacun va s'exprimer mais
dans le calme et l'ordre
déjà que c'est pas toujours très simple
de suivre tout le monde
par pitié un peu d'ordre madame la
rapporteure merci monsieur le président
je ne nie pas les difficultés qui
existent du fait qu' hier dans les
circonstances dont chacun se rappelle
l'article 1a a été supprimé pour autant
il a été indiqué qu'une nouvelle
délibération pourrait avoir lieu elle ne
pas avoir lieu qu'en fin de texte et si
nous réservons l'article 4 nous ne
pourrons quand délibérer avant la
seconde délibération sur l'article 1
ce qui n'aurait pas grand sens et ce qui
ne changerait pas grand chose donc nous
sommes dans une situation où quoi qu'il
arrive nous ne pouvons délibérer sur
l'article 4 qu'avant l'article 1
ça n'est pas très logique mais c'est
ainsi et moi je vous propose que nous
continuons nos débats de la façon dont
ils se sont amorcés c'est à dire de
continuer et de trancher sur l'article 4
dans l'ordre qui est celui du débat
partie de dons
vraiment ne dispersons pas les débats
madame cohen
écoutez moi personnellement je me trouve
certainement comme beaucoup de mes
collègues devant une situation assez
inédite jeu je ne va d'un point de vue
purement logique
nous allons nous prononcer sur un
article 4 comme ça en apesanteur et
défendre des amendements sur quelque
chose qui en réalité n'existe pas alors
mes chers collègues et ça n'est pas
polémique de ma part la majorité de
droite du sénat a pris ses
responsabilités hier et notamment le
président de la commission le président
de la commission spéciale en demandant
une nouvelle délibération
donc il faut que vous assumiez les
choses parce que là on va dont on va
parler mais vous pouvez aller comme le
dit monsieur karoutchi tout le monde à
la parole
vous pouvez la prendre et me contredire
ça ne me gêne pas le débat est toujours
instructif pour moi donc y'a pas de
soucis mais avouez quand même que parler
d'un article qui ne sera plus rattachés
et qui ne n'aura pas de sens et des
amendements qui ne vont pas tenir
on ne sait ubuesque sur un sujet qui est
extrêmement attendu parce que la pma
pour les femmes en couple et pour les
femmes non mariées est attendue depuis
des années donc ça ne donne pas une
image du sénat telle qu'elle devrait
être c'est à dire sereine et responsable
comme aux autres
je veux rappeler le fonctionnement
normal sauf ce qui serait de droit si la
commission devant de la réserve de
l'article 4 sauf je le redis si la
l'article 4 l'article 4 sera débattue
pour la bonne et simple raison que c'est
la règle c'est comme ça c'est pas moi
qui l'inventé une deuxième délibération
n'arrive qu'à l'extrême fin du texte et
par conséquent nous ne pouvons pas dire
que comme nous ne savons pas ce que
serait la deuxième délibération et le
vote sur la deuxième délibération on ne
fait pas l'article 4 donc soit la
commission me demande la réserve de
l'article 4 l et de droit soit la
commission ne me le demande pas et je
mets en délibéré l'article 4 et des
amendements qui vont avec
ça veut dire que si par malheur
quelconque ou par un bonheur quelconque
au terme de tout cela il n'y avait pas
d'article 1
évidemment ça changerait la nature des
choses mais nous ne sommes obligés dans
la mesure où on ne peut pas débattre de
l'article maintenant nous sommes obligés
de faire le déroulé du texte comme il
est inscrit à l'ordre du jour alors est
ce que la commission me demande la
réserve sur l'article 4 la commission me
répond non
en conséquence de quoi je met en
délibéré l'article 4 et nous appelons
les amendements j'appelle donc là
maintenant 21 rectifié bicici qu'est-ce
que sur quoi
sur assure l'article iv de vol entier
alors madame sillinger on sait jamais
monsieur le président je me permets de
prendre la parole à cet article je suis
inquiète depuis le début de l'examen en
deuxième lecture le texte a été vidé
temps de suppression temps d'amendements
passé en quelques secondes ayant un
impact durable pour la vie de nos
concitoyens
alors je prends la parole car la
suppression est encore là tapi dans
l'ombre de belles paroles et de grandes
idées mais en oubliant il semble la
réalité des français et des françaises
supprimer encore et toujours
l'article vivant à la filiation et
l'essentiel et qui est dommage que notre
texte cesse de répondre aux besoins des
citoyens tant dans leurs espoirs de
famille que dans le rôle crucial de la
filiation pour celles ci la protection
de tant de femmes de tant d'enfants et
tant de familles étaient au coeur de
notre texte
il est dommage de voir que par les
suppressions qui se suivent et se
ressemblent le texte ne devient qu'un
squelette sans réelle intention de
répondre aux attentes légitimes des
français de juillet merci monsieur le
président
on aurait aimé mener ce débat sur la
filiation sur les conséquences de
l'ouverture de la pma aux couples de
femmes et aux femmes sur les questions
de filiation qui sont des questions
importantes mais monsieur le président
on n'écrira pas un droit putatif je suis
désolé mais cette situation n'existe pas
à l'heure actuelle endroit puisque
l'article 1er n'existe pas dans cet
hémicycle
donc nous serons cohérent puisque la
commission ne souhaite pas l'être nous
nous retirons nos amendements nous ne
les défendront pas et nous ne
participerons pas au vote sur une
question qui n'existe pas à l'heure
actuelle le droit putatif n'est pas un
droit réel
vous avez créé un désordre législatives
de premier ordre ce n'est pas à nous de
nous j'allais dire vautrer dans ce
désordre législatif et bien d'un tacle
monsieur aulas
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres chers collègues je pense
qu'il faut redonner un peu de
rationalité notre débat il ya une chose
sur lequel nous sommes toutes et tous
d'accord c'est que l'article 1 n'a plus
de majorité
vous avez voté contre nous ne voterons
pas pour la seconde délibération va
confirmer ce vote il y aura de nouveau
un roger de l'article 1 parce que vous
voterez contre et que nous abstiendrons
donc en effet nous sommes dans une
situation où vous avez fait un choix
politique qu un choix politique fort qui
est de vider ce texte de la totalité de
ses articles je pense qu'il faut aller
au bout de cette logique politique et
moi je partage tout à fait la position
du groupe socialiste nous vous
laisserons détruire complètement ce
texte est d'assumer deux ans les femmes
le choix de société que vous avez fait
en leur nom
c'est notre point c
très bien j'en viens à l'amendement 21
rectifié pardon oui non mais
inscrivez-vous
franchement parce que là au fur et à
mesure voilà allons-y monsieur le
président merci mais s'inscrire dans ce
contexte est un peu compliqué d'avoir de
l'ordre dans ce grand désordre
ça fait quatre mois que je suis au sénat
je pensais trouver des choses ordonnée
et là on est dans un grand un grange rue
un grand jeu de quilles où il n'y a pas
de plus grand chose qui tient donc je ne
me range complètement à la vie de mes
collègues de gauche
dans ce contexte là nous retirons
également 12 amendements
eh bien monsieur le président la
commission j'avais demandé vous étiez
monsieur le président la commission oui
merci monsieur le président je je
voudrais revenir sur ce qui s'est passé
hier soir au moment du vote
nous savions tous qu'une partie de la
majorité du sénat allait voter contre le
texte
nous savions tous qu'une partie de la
majorité du sénat allait voter pour le
texte
ce que vous avez fait c'est que vous
êtes abstenu vous n'avez pas voté ce
texte je regrette de vous le dire - d'un
gontrie mais je ne fais que donner les
faits vous êtes abstenu et vous avez
faciliter le vote contre moi
personnellement en ce qui me concerne
j'ai voté pour
j'ai joué mais j'ai voté pour monsieur
j'ai voté pour je suis partie des 41 qui
ont voté peau et donc et la majorité à
assumer
assumer ça cette position elle a voté
contre
vous n'avez pas assumer je suis
absolument désolé qu'on attaque
l'article 4 et j'attaque les amendements
parce que le débat n'a pas avoir lieu
pardon de dire non non non non vous
ferez le débat sur les amendements
vous pouvez pas avoir le débat sur les
prises de parole sur l'article non par
conséquent prenez la parole sur les
amendes en si vous le souhaitez donc
amendement 21 rectifié be je donne la
parole à monsieur de lège sur le
président elle va être très court qu'il
ait retiré à l'est la parole sur le 12
rectifié qu'il prend madame berthet
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres chers collègues pour ma
part je présenterai cet amendement parce
que personne ne peut présumer à l'avance
du résultat d'une future délibération
sur l'article 1 en deuxième lecture
l'assemblée nationale a rétabli son
texte de première lecture qui fondent
l'établissement de la filiation de la
mère d'intention sur sa seule volonté
lance une amp est effectuée par un
couple de femmes tout en modifiant son
texte pour que la filiation de la mer
qui accouchent soit établie par
l'accouchement
il lui serait cependant aussi imposé de
reconnaître son enfant puisque la
reconnaissance conjointe anticipé des
deux femmes restent obligatoires
cet amendement vise donc à rétablir la
version de l'article iv adopté par le
sénat en première lecture mais
l'adoption est l'unique possibilité de
notre droit d'établir une filiation
élective sous le contrôle du juge est
dans l'intérêt de l'enfant pour
l'établissement de la filiation à
l'égard de la femme qui accouche
l'amendement ne changerait rien au droit
existant pour celles à l'égard de la
femme qui n'a pas participé à la
procréation
il propose l'établir par la voix d'une
procédure d'adoption rénové et accélérer
ouverte aux couples non mariés à la
diligence de l'adoptant l'adoption
pourrait donc être prononcé dans le mois
de la naissance de l'enfant est établie
au jour même de sa naissance de façon
rétroactive au jour même du dépôt de la
requête en adoption
ce dispositif à deux méritent il permet
d'établir la filiation de l'enfant issu
de la mp lorsqu'un couple de famille a
recours en toute sécurité juridique
ils utilisent les outils du droit
existant sans bouleverser les principes
fondamentaux de la filiation
par cohérence le présent amendement
supprime le régime transitoire
rétroactif introduit par l'assemblée
nationale en deuxième lecture
ouvrant le bénéfice de la reconnaissance
conjointe aux couples de femmes ayant eu
recours à une amp à l'étranger avant son
autorisation en france
merci à vis de la commission le
rapporteur l'avis de la commission est
favorable monsieur le président sur ce
système d'établissement de la filiation
qui présente l'avantagé de permettre
d'instaurer un lien de filiation de
qualité sans toutefois ébranler le
système de filiation qui existe en droit
français actuellement et qui
correspondra à plus de 99% des enfants
qui vont continuer à naître en france la
femme qui accouche et la mer c'est le
principe du droit de la filiation pour
établir la filiation maternelle et la
femme qui n'accouche pas et qui ne peut
pas avoir de lien biologique avec cet
enfant bénéficiera de la filiation
élective la filiation de choix qui
existe déjà en france qui est l'adoption
avec le système de sécurité que madame
berthet a présenté en présentant son
amendement qui consiste à ce que si
l'adoption devait être refusée par une
des deux femmes le juge pour elle a
prononcé et la filiation adoptive serait
rétroactive au jour dès le dépôt de la
requête qui peut être le jour de la
naissance de l'enfant
voilà donc un lien de filiation de
qualité et je rappelle qu'en matière de
droit de la filiation
ça n'est pas la technique
d'établissement de la filiation qui est
vecteur d'égalité en réalité un père qui
est père par présomption de paternité
n'a pas une valeur supérieure un père
qui serait père par reconnaissance ni
même à un père qui se répètent par
adoption
une technique est une technique ce qui
est important c'est la relation entre le
parent et l'enfant
et quelle que soit la technique de
filiation adopté cette relation est de
même nature les droits et les devoirs
entre le parent et l'enfant sont de même
nature
de sorte qu il me semble
que cet amendement a donc cette ce
double avantage que de préserver le
système de filiation existants et de
donner à ses enfants et à ses femmes un
lien de filiation de qualité avis
favorable merci avait du gouvernement
monsieur le garde des sceaux monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
vous disiez tout à l'heure madame la
sénatrice que vous ne saviez pas ce
qu'il adviendrait de l'article 1
vous avez raison et en matière de
justice il ya toujours également un aléa
voyous quid d'une adoption qui ne serait
pas prononcée judiciairement je veux
rappeler simplement humainement sans
dogmatisme
il s'agit d'un pro d'un projet commun
une maman accouche la filiation est
établie de façon traditionnelle et celle
qui n'accouche pas devoir recourir
dites vous souhaitez vous à l'adoption
quid du juge qui n'a prononcent pas
deuxièmement dans ce délai entre la
naissance de l'enfant et le prononcé de
l'adoption
s'il ya des mesures extrêmement
importante qui peut les prendre seule la
maman qui a accouché
troisième élément pardon ça n'est pas
rien si la maman qui doit adopter moeurs
quelles sont les conséquences
successorale est ce que l'enfant n'a
droite a rien de la part de sa deuxième
maman au motif que la procédure serait
singulièrement plus complexe plus longue
et je le redis aléatoire
trois raisons qui font avec pragmatisme
et là encore sans aucun dogme que le
gouvernement est défavorable madame la
sénatrice à l'amendement que vous avez
présenté et bien explications de vote
monsieur chasse un merci ce président
sur présente des commissions numis
effectivement je viens d'écouter
attentivement monsieur le ministre
donc ces arguments effectivement sont
importants mais comme je lé fais en
première lecture
donc je pense que effectivement et comme
l'a dit dédie le sénat la femme qui
accouche verrait sa filiation tout à
fait normale établie selon droit
existant qui est la mère est là la
seconde mais on aurait une procédure
d'adoption simplifier accélérer alors
est-ce que ça peut être proposés
antérieurement et réalisé jusque le jour
de l'accouchement peut-être qu'il ya des
choses à adapter mais cette proposition
utiliser les droits existants sans
bouleverser les principes de la
filiation et donc j'approuve cet
amendement monsieur hainaut et monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre je
suis favorable à la pma pour les couples
de femmes je suis favorable à la pma
pour les femmes seules
je suis défavorable est pma post mortem
et donc je veux exprimer dans ce cadre
sur la la filiation
vous avez évoqué les aléas monsieur le
ministre c'est c'est eh bien évidemment
une question qu'on peut se poser mais la
vie est un aléa au fond permanent jeu
pense que nous avons la filiation
charnelle la filiation pas présomptions
pour ce qui concerne le le père nous
avons la filiation par adoption et même
étant favorables à la pma pour lé couple
de femmes et pour les femmes seules
je ne pense pas qu'il faille bousculer
le code civil et la filiation et que le
travail qui a été fait par la commission
spéciale du du sénat permet parfaitement
à égalité de droits et de devoirs parce
que dans votre intervention hier
monsieur le ministre vous aviez évoqué
le fait qu'ils avaient je sais pas si
vous avez vraiment parler comme ça mais
une forme de question de hiérarchie ou
de légitimité par rapport à la mer qui
accouchent et par rapport à celle qui
adoptent bon ben si vous me dites non
c'est mieux mais je pense que si on
aborde une nouvelle filiation peut-être
que on fragilise ray en faisant cela la
la filiation par adoption est donc dans
la logique de ce qui a été présenté par
la commission spéciale à titre personnel
je voterai cet amendement jour merci mr
c'est madame guillotin lui rapidement
juste pour dire que je voterai donc
contre cet amendement
et comme gélifiant dg étant plutôt
satisfaite de l'écriture tel qu'il était
sorti de l'assemblée nationale donc nous
voterons bien évidemment contre et
préférons l'autre mode de filiation que
le mode de l'adoption très bien je suis
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe l'est républicain sur
l'amendement de 12
je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est favorable
l'avis du gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin est tout
r voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 71
sur l'amendement numéro 12 rectifier
compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs au groupe politique est
notifiée à la présidence nombre de
votants 228 nombre de suffrages exprimés
212 pour l'adoption 151 contre 61
le sénat a adopté en conséquence cet
amendement écrivant l'article 4
l'article 4 est ainsi adopté je vais
donc mettre aux voix l'ensemble du
projet de loi
monsieur le ministre j'allais demander
s'il y avait des explications de vote
mais nous allons commencer par si vous
me le permettrais madame la présidente
comme l'a indiqué tout à l'heure le
garde des sceaux en vertu du principe
constitutionnel de sincérité et de
clarté du débat
l'article premier n'étant pas en passe
d'être rétabli à ce que je constate
puisque vous alliez passer vous alliez
soumettre madame la présidente
l'ensemble du texte au vote des
sénateurs si la suppression donc est
maintenue de cet article 1er il convient
de voter en connaissance de cause sur
l'article 4 qui tire les conséquences de
l'article 1er en matière de filiation et
donc pour une fois encore la clarté la
sincérité des débats le gouvernement
demande nouvelle délibération sur
l'article 4 lui égard au fait que
l'article 1er n'a pas été rétablie
aligner des propos tenus par le garde
des sceaux cet après midi
quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur le président mesdames est
présente dans la mesure où ils demandent
à nouveau sur un article a déjà été
votée c'est le sénat qui doit s'exprimer
sur le sujet par un vote global
d'après le règlement
y at il un orateur contre
donc en fait selon les autorités sur
l'article
oui sérieux le lourd à porter le
président de la commission
bon
donc suite à là l'explication du
président je consulte donc le sénat sur
la demande de la seconde délibération
donc je mets aux voix pour monsieur
juillet madame la présidente je suis
désolé mais je pense qu'on peut quand
même prendre un peu le temps de la
discussion parce que quand application
le règlement intérieur prévoit qu' il
n'y a pas d'explications de vote quand
il ya une deuxième délibération donc
c'est pour ça que je vais aux voix
immédiatement
je suis désolé monsieur julien s'est pas
vraiment vous interrompre mai ainsi on
est décidés par le règlement intérieur
donc moi je mets aux voix sans
explication de vote
on ne peut pas madame la présidente on
voudrait comprendre exactement ce qui
m'est ova donnez nous deux minutes s'il
vous plaît il nous a été indiqué lorsque
l'article 1 a été rejetée le crest dans
la commission nous alors expliqué qu'il
y aurait une seconde délibération qui le
demanderaient sur l'article 1
c'est ce qui a été dit indiqué dans cet
hémicycle et qui figure au procès-verbal
de la séance
le garde des sceaux nous a effectivement
indiqué que si l'article 1 était
définitivement supprimée demanderait une
seconde délibération sur l'article 4 ce
que vient de confirmer le secrétaire
d'état
le président la commission maintenant
nous informe que contrairement à ce qui
a été indiqué les mici qu'il n'y aura
pas de seconde délibération sur
l'article 1
donc nous nous constatons que le débat
que nous avons eu sur l'article 4 est
effectivement un débat qui était biaisé
voilà et nous demandons que un minimum
d'ordre les i cette histoire mieux que
nous puissions de nouveau effectivement
débattent de l'article 4 alors je
demande s'il ya un autre accord
contraint donc
donc vous êtes contre la seconde
délibération
vous êtes pour la sommes d'accord
normalement il n'ya pas d'explications
de vote
allez-y monsieur bas madame la
présidente je prends la parole contre la
demande du gouvernement de seconde
délibération sur l'article 4 je
considère que cet article 4 tel qu'il a
été adopté de nouveaux par le sénat
aujourd'hui comme l'an dernier permet
d'affirmer avec clarté la position du
sénat en matière de filiation
s'il devait y avoir ouverture de
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
pour les couples de femmes
je souhaite que en vue des débats au
sein d'une future commission mixte
paritaire le vote du débat du sénat sur
la question de la filiation puissent
être pris en compte
en ayant été réaffirmée avec solennité
et c'est la raison pour laquelle dès
lors que nous avons considéré qu'il y
avait lieu de débattre de l'article 4
malgré le fait que l'article 1er n'avait
pas été adopté je considère qu'il faut
s'en tenir à ce choix qui a été fait en
toute connaissance de cause
au cours de notre débat il n'y a pas de
raison donc d'y revenir
alors
écoutez jeu puisque les pour et contre
se sont exprimés je consulte donc le
sénat par un vote sur la demande de
seconde les délibérations tel que
demandé par le gouvernement
est ce qu'il ya une demande de scrutin
public sur cette demande de
délibérations eh bien il faut qu'elle
soit formule il faudrait que je reçois
un petit papier vert
papier vert est en route donc préparez
vous à scrutin public
nous allons voter sur la demande du
gouvernement de seconde délibération sur
l'article 4 donc il y aura à se
prononcer contre ou pour est-ce que
c'est clair parfait donc j'attends le
petit papier vert
il est formulée par plusieurs groupes
c'est bon
l'écho des astuces puis donc saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public par lé groupe
crc e socialiste écologiste pascal
patrie socialiste
voilà donc c'est par les trois groupes
que je vous ai cités sur la seconde
délibération du gouvernement sur
l'article 4 il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin est ouvert
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 79
compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs au groupe politique est
notifiée à la présidence nombre de
votants 344 nombre de suffrages exprimés
343 pour l'adoption 129 contre 214
le sénat n'a donc pas adopter cette
proposition de délibération
une seconde délibération sur l'article 4
je vais donc mettre aux voix l'ensemble
du projet de loi y at il des demandes
d'explications de vote
avant ce vote monsieur salma
j'avais bien dit madame la présidente
merci je m'étais déjà exprimé hier sur
le caractère assez assez dantesques de
ce projet de loi là on nous demande de
nous exprimer sur une un projet de loi
qui est tronqué avec un article 1 qui
était quand même un des piliers à des
éléments essentiels et il a carrément
disparu
c'est quand même assez incroyable
surtout que on nous avait annoncé hier
également une procédure qui visait à
reconvoquer la commission spéciale pour
préparer un nouveau vote sur l'article
donc voilà la procédure a l'air d'être
assez fluctuante je ne sais pas
exactement
il y à un règlement mais ce règlement
adorait certainement besoin d'être un
peu affiné parce que la nounou nous
flottons complètement donc nous ne
pourrons pas voté contre cette loi nous
ne pouvons pas voter pour
donc il nous reste qu'une seule solution
c'est l'abstention mais c'est vraiment à
grand regret merci cher collègue
monsieur mohammad folie oui merci madame
la présidente
ce texte qui porte est temps d'avancer
et qui méritait un débat serein et
constructif se retrouve dépourvu de
presque toute sa substance
après un examen pour le moins tourmenté
voter ce projet de loi sans son article
premier et son article 2 est impensable
pour une majorité de notre groupe donc
vous perdez pays choisir donc de voter
contre ce texte pour une bonne partie
d'entre nous non pas parce que nous ne
souhaitons pas nous positionner sur les
mesures qu'il portait bien au contraire
c'est parce qu'ils ne portent plus grand
chose que nous votons contre ce texte
qui est aujourd'hui complètement
dénaturé la collègue madame cohen
merci madame la présidente
moi je suis scandalisé par ce qui se
passe au sénat scandalisé
parce que finalement il ya une manne
honnêteté qui s'est produit dans
l'hémicycle quand on nous dit qu'il y à
une seconde délibération sur l'article 1
et que cette seconde délibération n'a
pas lieu
je suis désolé j'appelle ça une
malhonnêteté intellectuelle pour le
moins surtout qui hier mes chers
collègues en fait qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé vous avez vidé
l'article 1 de tout son contenu et c'est
ce que vous vouliez dès le départ mais
vous n'avez pas voulu assumer les
désaccords que vous avez dans vos rangs
parce que à droite vous êtes divisés là
dessus il ya une partie de la droite qui
est farouchement contre
et une autre partie qui est plus nuancé
et qui pensaient que la gauche et
soutiendrait mais assumez votre
désaccord il ne fait pas porter sur les
autres les responsabilités doit
désaccord vous ne voulez pas aujourd'hui
majoritairement que toutes les femmes
aient accès à la mp c'est ça qui va
sortir de notre séance ce soir est ce
qui est très grave
mes chers collègues et c'est pour ça
qu'avec le groupe crc eux nous sommes
particulièrement en colère ce qui est
très grave c'est que que vont dire les
gens à la suite de ces deux jours de
débats ils vont se demander à quoi sert
le sénat
et ça ne nous sort pas grandi parce que
nous voulons effectivement faire bouger
les choses dans notre pays chacun avec
des lignes politiques sans doute
différente mais là on a montré quoi une
inutilité de nos débats et moi je suis
particulièrement colère parce que
finalement ce jugement il va pas
seulement par cette portée contre la
droite
mais sur l'ensemble de la représentation
parlementaire et 7 votre responsabilité
et c'est pourquoi je dénonce ce qui
s'est passé et nous dire qu'on va finir
le wake on a pris dix minutes mais pas
dix minutes avant qu'il n'y aurait pas
de seconde délibération
quand j'ai interrogé pour savoir mais
attendez on va finir de d'examiner la
loi
on sait pas et c'était un peu tout d'un
coup on nous a dit
dix minutes avant mais vous nous avez
pris en otage
ça n'est pas en toute connaissance de
cause et ça il faut que ça soit
clairement dit dans le procès verbal
nous avons été trompés et en plus de ça
cette loi n'est pas celle qu'on devait
porter par rapport à la bioéthique
l'attend pour les femmes la tente pour
la recherche la tente pour l'éthique
c'est un scandale
monsieur juillet pour explication de
vote merci mme la présidente
à tout le moins c'est un naufrage et
c'est un naufrage libre vraiment nous
attriste parce que quand nous avons
débuté cette discussion
je disais mes craintes nos craintes
d'une radicalisation des positions du
fait que la discussion allait être très
difficile en seconde lecture
mais je crois qu'on ne pouvait pas
imaginer que la procédure se déroulerait
de cette façon c'était le chaos hier
dans l'hémicycle
et c'est le naufrage en fin de
discussion
nous voilà avec un texte qui est privé
d'une part significative
vous pouvez discuter de sa légitimité à
être là mais elle était là et le
résultat c'est que vous avez jd ce texte
et in fine et je partage ce qu'a dit ma
collègue laurence cohen vous nous avez
laissé croire qu'il y aurait une seconde
délibération il n'y a pas de seconde
délibération sur l'article 1
et ça ça ne peut ça ne peut pas être
simplement une personne qui n'est pas en
capacité de tenir ce qu'elle a dit c'est
que les conditions politiques dans
l'hémicycle fait que vous n'étiez pas en
capacité vous la majorité sénatoriale de
tenir cet engagement
vous n'avez pas été capable dans la
journée d'aujourd'hui de nous présenter
un nouvel article rhin qu'on puisse
discuter parce que vos antagonismes sont
telles qu encore une fois vous les
reporter sur nous et vous ne les avez
pas assumer et ça ça n'est pas ce ne
sont pas les bonnes conditions d'une
discussion parlementaire
on peut s'opposer sur le fond on admet
la sanction du suffrage universel tous
en démocratie et particulièrement ceux
cet hémicycle
on en a l'habitude on ne peut pas
accepter de telles conditions d'un débat
on ne peut pas accepter qu'on nous mène
en bateau on ne peut pas accepter qu'on
nous fasse discuter un article alors que
l'article qui le légitime n'existe pas
et nous expliquer que c'est pas grave
parce que plus tard on en discutera à
l'arrivée la pma ne sera pas ouverte
certains s'en satisferont pour toutes
les femmes nous nous le déplorons la
recherche française ne sortira pas
renforcé du texte que vous allez
adopter ce texte vous allez adopter
récents nous parce que ce texte
c'est le résultat d'un gâchis monsieur
hainaut merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre vous aviez dit
monsieur jomier en début de séance lors
de la discussion générale qui avait un
péché originel à cette loi parce qu'il y
avait la partie sociétale et puis la
partie bioéthique
alors est ce un péché véniel est ce un
porche péché mortel
voilà moi j'ai pas peur de le dire je
suis pour la pma pour les couples de
femmes
pma pour les femmes seules et je suis
opposé à la pma post mortem
voilà les conditions du débat ont été
difficiles particulière c'est vrai mais
c'est pas parce qu'on perd une partie
serait la pma con qu'on doit brûler le
stade et donc moi je reconnais que
j'aurais préféré un projet de loi dans
sa globalité avec l'article 1 mais il
n'empêche la qualité des débats que nous
avons eus sur la bioéthique fait que je
trouve que ce serait dommage de ne pas
voter cette partie du projet de loi au
fond véritablement bioéthique pas
sociétal mais véritablement bioéthique
et je pense que voter en faveur de de ce
projet de loi a abouti à la fin de notre
discussion permet quand même de marquer
le travail du sénat je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
monsieur gontard pour explication de
vote
oui merci merci madame la présidente je
vais pas reprendre ce qui a été dit par
parme et mes deux collègues
madame cohen et et monsieur juillet mais
quand même quel spectacle
on donne ce soir et je dirai ce qu'on a
donné pendant pendant ces deux jours
parce que oui il ya eu des débats
intéressants
on a eu des moments particulièrement je
dirais fort où on a pu discuter on a pu
débattre et je pense que ça c'était une
belle image du sénat et c'est celle
qu'on doit donner
et puis il ya ce qu'on voit ce qu'on vit
maintenant ce qu'on a ce qu'on a vécu
sept
je ne sais même pas comment le comment
le déterminer de voter un texte sur la
pma on se retrouve où enfin on a plus
d'articles sur la pma vous nous avez
fait voter un article 4 qui n'a plus
aucune lieu d'être et vous ne souhaitez
pas qu'on puisse y revenir dessus
alors que les conditions au totalement
changé on est donc dans quelque chose
qui n'a plus ni queue ni tête et tout ça
pour ça et moi je suis particulièrement
triste
en tant que parlementaire de l'image
qu'on peut donner qu'on peut donner ce
soir et de et de l'image du sénat parce
que je pense que c'est pas c'est pas
celle là et c'est pas et c'est pas la
réalité
alors moi j'ai envie de vous demander
sur ce côté de l'hémicycle
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en un an
puisqu'il ya à peine un an en première
en première lecture on a voté un texte
on n'était pas d'accord puisque on avait
eu des échanges mais en est sorti avec
un vote pour la pma pour pour toutes les
femmes alors bien sûr il n'y avait pas
le remboursement on n'était pas d'accord
mais en tout cas on était sorti avec un
texte issu du sénat
ce soir on va sortir avec un texte
tronçonner un texte sur la pma sans pma
et j'ai l'impression qu'en fait tout
simplement vous n'assumez pas vous
n'assumez pas vos divisions vos totale
vaut des visions voir vos déchirements
au sein de au sein de la droite et vous
n'assumez pas le fait que ben vous ne
voulez pas de cette pma tout court mais
à ce moment là il fallait argumenté là
dessus il fallait voter là dessus et ne
pas arriver à c'était
ps de nous mener en bateau arrivé là à
une heure du matin pour nous dire non il
y aurait pas de deuxième délibération
alors qu'on nous l'a fait croire pendant
toute la journée
j'ai quelques escales et cette méthode
franchement enfin moi je suis scandalisé
c'est ce qui a été dit mais je pense que
c'est le mot qu'on doit retenir
scandalisé parce que le spectacle que
vous nous avez offert ce soir monsieur
fialaire pour explication de vote la
présidente monsieur le ministre en
arrivant récemment dans cette assemblée
j'étais mais heureux et fier de
rejoindre ce que clemenceau appelait la
chambre de modération de la vie
parlementaire
j'espérais y trouver de la sérénité la
possibilité d'aborder des textes
importants pour la société pour d'autres
coeur commun et là je suis très triste
c'est une véritable frustration
autant les débats et les discussions en
commission ont été intéressants autant
j'ai pas reconnu dans l'hémicycle le
même état d'esprit en voyant des choses
un petit peu se figer et c'est très
violent ce qu'on ressent ce soir de ne
pas pouvoir aller au bout d'un texte
même du traité de se prononcer
d'échangés même si on ne devait pas être
majoritaire sur ce qui faisait presque
les sens le plus essentiel de ce texte
c'est vrai qu'après vivre des débats en
attendant une revoyure sur des articles
qui au dernier moment nous sont
volley et bien je trouve ça
effectivement violent je trouve que
c'est pas non plus une belle image que
nous donnons à l'ensemble de la société
de ce que doit être le parlement de ce
que doit être notre hémicycle notre
chambre justement une modération qui
devait pondéré qu'il devait discuter
le texte qui est également étudié à
l'assemblée
et c'est avec une grande tristesse que
on ne peut pas voter le texte qui nous
sera proposé
merci cher collègue madame de roche
merci madame la présidente moi je
voulais rendre rappeler quand même ce
qui s'est passé hier jusqu à
l'amendement de monsieur chassaing des
fusées pour daniel sein de le cibler
ainsi mais nous avons vu un débat qui
était un débat normal bon alors certes
il y avait un point sur lequel nous
n'avons pas voté la même chose que l'an
passé c'était sur l'ouverture aux femmes
ce aux femmes seules
bon je suis à l'aise pour le dire parce
que moi j'étais opposé à l'amendement
qui restreignait à partir moi j'étais
opposé à la pma l'extension la pma
partir au moment où elle avait été votée
puisque c'est quand même ce qui a été
fait lorsqu'on a lorsqu'on n'a pas voté
les amendements de suppression
l'article 1er à partir du moment où
elles avaient été donc votez donc on
était resté constant sur le vote de l'an
passé par rapport à cela
moi je ne souhaitais pas qu'on fasse une
distinction entre les femmes seules et
les couples de femmes
bon ça a été voté comme ça mais dans un
débat tout à fait normal en connaissance
de cause
ce n'était pas la même chose qu'en
première lecture mais si on doit
obligatoirement voté en deuxième lecture
ce qui était la première lecture c'est
pas la peine d'en faire
je dirige est bien dit à ce moment-là
qu'il y avait eu un renouvellement et
que les boîtes ouvertes différents bons
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est que
en fin de première une soirée si je puis
dire le
président nous a dit on va faire un
scrutin public et ensuite on stoppe la
séance or c'est parce qu'il s'est passé
on a fait ce qu est un public et il nous
a fait à la va-vite voté deux
amendements celui de madame benbassa et
celui de monsieur chasse avec la moitié
des collègues étaient déjà rendu en haut
les mici et là il ya eu un pataquès sur
sur le vote sur l'amendement chassaing
et lorsqu'on a demandé une nouvelle
délibération ne connaissons pas lui
valait une technique très juridiques du
sénat - naïvement je pensais qu un
retrait la renonciation et que ça
s'arrêterait là
non c'était en effet quelque chose
d'assez compliqué qui était de re
délibérer sur l'article 1er mais qu'est
ce que vous attendiez de cette nouvelle
délibération si c'était qu'on revienne
sur le vote sur les femmes seules si
c'était qu'on refasse tout le débat
initial non on va pas chaque fois qu'il
ya un vote qui ne vous convient pas
redélibérer pour arriver à avoir un vote
qui soit conforme à ce que vous
souhaitez donc
non mais donc qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que même si on avait re délibéré on
aurait supprimé le vote positif sur
l'amendement daniel chassaing et
honoraires voter l'identit honnêtement
et intellectuellement il fallait revoter
le texte tel qu'il avait été voté
jusqu'à l'amendement litigieux daniel
chasse
sinon je ne mais si c'est un amendement
dont on contestait les conditions du
vote
donc moi je ne comprends pas c'est un
peu hystérique du débat alors que les
choses sont claires c'est retourner lui
ce vote seul vote de l'article 1er ou
nous il ya eu un vote en effet séparés
au sein de notre résidence parce qu'il
ya voir qui vous avez dépassé votre
favorable et d'autres qui n'y sont pas
favorables
mais si vous souhaitiez que la pma soit
ôtée pour les couples de femmes
il fallait pas vous abstenir soit la
soirée monsieur chassant puisque on a
beaucoup parlé de vous vous avez un
temps d'explications de vote
madame madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je suis président de la
commission menant à porter à écoutez moi
je souhaite bien effectivement dire que
ces trois jours on était quand même
riche dans le débat donc ça c'est qu'un
important mais c'est vrai que je suis
vraiment désaccord avec le projet des
articles 1 et 2 de ce projet de loi
parce que c'est les deux piliers du
texte qui perd quand même une grande
partie de sa portée alors olivier nau la
dir-est certaines choses au niveau de la
bioéthique et ud6 a eu des précisions
pour les pour les chercheurs des
précisions aussi du cdah pour les
embryons chimérique pas tout ça parce
que la majorité c'est ce que la majorité
souhaitait la commission donc je
regrette la décision du sénat aussi de
restreindre l'ouverture de la pma à
l'article bon ça a été dit parce que si
vous voulez dans la mesure où une femme
seule peut adopter un enfant
il me semble que nous pouvons aussi
l'autorisé à procréer la portée initiale
de cet article est de permettre à toute
femme qui le souhaitent de pouvoir
enfanter quelle que soit sa situation
personnelle ou son orientation notre
société évolue j'ai dit dans mon
intervention les structures familiales
également et je pense que nous devions
en tant qu'initiateur accompagner ces
changements nous l'avons nous avions
voté jusqu'à effectivement cette cet
amendement que je regrette d'avoir fait
finalement si basculement alors je leur
précise quand même c'était un amendement
qui ne porte que sur la possibilité de
transférer un embryon l'embryon on en a
parlé déjà ses débuts de la vie donc
lorsque la démarche de pma est déjà
enclenché à partir du moment où il
envoyait forme est donc je considère que
si vous voulez j'ai considéré que
c'était pas juste d'interdire à la
conjointe de poursuivre la démarche de
pma pour que le couple a souhaité il ya
d'autres pays qui le font ce n'était pas
extraordinaire
c'est l'espagne le royaume uni et ça
représente vraiment quelque chose de
très très peu au niveau national c'est
simplement une possibilité donc le
comité national d'éthique d'ailleurs été
favorable donc je regrette aussi le le
roger du sénat pour l'auto conservation
des gamètes
nous avions collègues vous dépasser
alors l'auto conservation des gamètes
est un moyen de lutter contre
l'infertilité lit et là je termine ma
dame pour le président ou à d'autres
facteurs peu connu les femmes sont
maintenant libres de leur corps elles ne
se laissent pas impressionner et oui
elle se laisse pas impressionner et
quand elles veulent une grossesse elles
le font c'est pas le patron d'un même
film cherche donc voilà je voulais vous
dire simplement que je m'abstiendrai
malheureusement même si cher collègue
madame guillotin oui merci madame la
présidente je vais juste démarré avec
l'espoir avec lequel j'ai entamé
l'examen de ce texte lors de la
discussion générale en pensant qu'on
aurait un texte qui était au moins aussi
avancé que celui de l'année dernière
voire un peu plus parce qu'on avait
j'avais nourri cet espoir-là par le
biais de du vote des quatre semaines de
congé parental en disant qu'on était en
fait sur un sénat avec une lancée plus
tôt plutôt sociétalement aller coûte le
texte a effectivement bien démarrer
jusqu'à l'amendement à l'amendement post
mortem moi j'ai pas la même lecture de
ce qui s'est passé je me suis pas
exprimé au moment de cet amendement ma
lecture n'a pas été la même
j'ai le sentiment que sur la droite de
l'hémicycle
il ya une focalisation sur l'amendement
que j'ai déposée en poste mortelle il y
avait un scrutin public il est pas passé
certes mais je pense que derrière il ya
eu un effet de surprise et un vote à
main levée mais qui n'est pas tant liée
un désordre d'organisation de la
présidence mais bien une démobilisation
sur la partie droite de cette assemblée
les temps quand on fait un match tant
que le sifflet n'est pas sifflé le
dernier coup de ballon ou voilà en tout
il ya une démobilisation le vote à main
levée a été perdu et est derrière moi je
le pense même si vous ne vous énervez
pas je me suis jamais exprimé
c'est la première fois que je me serais
me laissez moi mix prix mais pas chez
vous après mais laissez moi au moins
m'exprimer c'est ce que je pense et ce
que j'ai ressenti en génie de rancoeur
ni d'animosité mais je dis juste ce que
je pense ensuite et derrière ça tout est
parti un peu à vau l'eau
voilà c'est parti à vau l'eau on devait
revoter on n'a pas voté donc les
explications elles sont ce qu'elles sont
aujourd'hui on nous demande un vote sur
la totalité du texte il ya plus
d'articles 1
nous on était très favorable à
l'extension de la pma pour toutes les
femmes les femmes seules et de manière
rembourser ça n'existe plus l'article 2
sur les dons de gamètes ça n'existe plus
l'affiliation du coup l'article iv n'a
plus de sens
donc concernant notre groupe on n'était
pas tout à fait en accord non plus avec
ce qui est sorti sur la recherche en
étant plutôt favorable en et en allant
un peu plus loin sur la recherche
donc voilà en tout toute connaissance de
cause on votera donc contre ce qu'il
reste de ce texte mais je vous dit il
n'y a pas deux il ya aucune animosité et
pas de souci c'est juste l'expression de
ce que j'ai vécu de cette séance merci
merci cher collègue monsieur ozu liesse
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je voudrais exprimer toute ma
solidarité aux sénateurs chassaing je
trouve profondément a juste la façon
dont le taux but le taux et le
législatif que nous menons ici vous est
incriminé chers collègues vous êtes bien
évidemment absolument étranger à ce
qu'il se fasse ici je tenais à vous le
dire
rappelez vous chers collègues comment
vous avez abordé ce texte vous nous avez
dit s'agit pas d'une loi de bioéthique
il s'agit d'une loi sur la pma et c'est
comme ça que politiquement vous avez
abordé ce texte vous avez décidé par
l'article 1 de rejeter la pme donc vous
rejeter ce texte
je crois que pour l'intelligent
l'intelligibilité de nos débats il
faudrait maintenant que vous assumiez
cette position est que vous nous disiez
l'a publiquement que vous trouvez votre
est contre cette loi et contre la pop
life et images je pense que ça serait
une clarification qui c'est essentiel et
ça redonnerait un peu de rationalité à
notre débat alors je ne peux pas vous je
vous obliger à vous exprimer
mais je pense que sincèrement ça serait
quand même une bonne chose pour que les
français les françaises qui va qui vont
nous regarder qu'on prenne un peu de ce
qui va se passer parce que là ce qui va
se passer
il ya des collègues qui sont pour cette
loi qui vont voter contre et d'autres
qui sont côte qui vont public et qui
vont voter pour qui va comprendre quoi
que ce soit de ce que nous faisons donc
je pense que le moment de vérité est
important et chaque gros doigts où
chaque seconde doit en conscience dire
s'il est pour ou s'il est contre la pma
et à partir de cela
nous définirons notre vote sur sur cette
loi merci madame la présidente monsieur
gâte pour explication de vote
merci madame la présidente en ce qui me
concerne moi je ne prendrai pas part à
ce vote
bernard jomier a parlé d'un naufrage
mais ce naufrage je crains que ce soit
véritablement le sénat qui soit en train
de se saborder
il s'est sabordé sur la base du non
respect d'une parole qui était donné et
qui n'est pas respecté et qui a biaisé
d'une certaine façon les débats j'ai pu
vous l'avez constaté exprimé moines
sensibilité complètement différente et
je remercie d'ailleurs mon groupe
politique de m'avoir permis de
m'exprimer et en toute liberté de voter
à l'encontre de la majorité du groupe et
parfois de me singularise et je pense
que notre procédure parlementaire est
aujourd'hui dénaturé et c'est je dirais
le rôle du sénat qui peut être remis en
cause donc moi je ne veux pas participer
à cette mascarade
donc en conséquence je ne prendrai donc
pas part au vote madame meunier pour
explication de vote à la colère exprimée
par notre collègue laurence cohen à
l'exaspération à la déception à la
compréhension exprimé par une collègue
des groupes de ce côté-là de l'hémicycle
moi je rajoute un goût amer et une
certaine amertume de ce qui se passe au
sénat cela a été dit je pas le répéter
ça ne ressemble pas à nos débats on en a
eu d'aussi difficile on en aura encore
sur d'autres textes on arrive toujours
un peu à l'image de la commission
spéciale a trouvé les mots l'attitude et
les votes qui vont avec
quand bruno retailleau en discussion
générale vous avez parlé de textes et de
contexte serait déjà dû nous alerter et
je pense que le contexte de 2021 n'est
vraiment pas le même que celui du
contexte de la première lecture de 2020
il a pesé
il a pesé et parfois sur cet article 1
comme sur l'article 4 sont surtout des
postures tu dois le dire avec une
certaine autorité
il a fait part et a fait place à des
votes qui encore une fois aurait pu être
un peu plus nuancé en tout cas on aurait
pu le penser
voilà donc cette deuxième lecture ne
ressemble vraiment pas à la première est
mon vote sera différent du premier je ne
voterai pas ce texte
monsieur le président de la commission
spéciale monsieur milon merci madame la
présidente je vais revenir sur ce qui a
été dit et je comprends bien mais jamais
bien le fait que le chacun dans son
domaine de préférence ou dans son
domaine d'exigence par rapport au vote
qui aurait pu avoir lieu subissez une
véritable frustration frustration d'un
côté puisque la pma pour les couples a
été votée fausse citation de l'autre
plus que la pma pour femmes seules n'a
pas été votée
frustrations des uns parce que la pma
post mortem a été votée frustration des
autres parce qu'il ne voulait pas
qu'elle soit votée frustration de moi
même
tu vas nous voient différemment parmi
vous tous le plus frustré pour une
raison simple c'est que moi je suis
favorable à la pma pour femmes seules
la pma pour femmes en couple à la pma
post mortem et à la gpa et là vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec moi pour que
puisse frustré dans cette affaire c'est
encore moi au bout du compte et malgré
cela ben je regarde ça avec le sourire
et j'admets que ou au bout du compte nos
travaux ont été intéressants j'avais dit
à monsieur taquet que j'attaquerai
gouvernement dans cette affaire et je
vais le faire bien évidemment en toute
amitié avec elle rien mais ce que j'ai
dit hier au début de de notre de nos
travaux que le texte sur la pma est un
texte social n'est pas un texte de
bioéthique
s'il avait été séparé du texte d'à
on aurait peut-être eu la même
discussion on n'aurait pas eu le même
problème
là on est en train de mélanger ce qu'a
dit fort bien non pour ne pas citer
personne
les collègues s'est dit fort bien un
certain nombre de nos collègues dans la
salle le texte de bi bioéthique
hormis pma n'est pas un texte si mauvais
que cela
les amendements de bernard jomier ont
été voter les amendements de
corinne imbert ont été voté le texte qui
est sortie aujourd'hui du sénat est
sensiblement le texte qui est sorti du
sénat ya un an en arrière et finalement
il vous avait satisfait à l'époque
puisque vous l'aviez voter le seul
problème donc c'est le problème de la
pma je vous dis vous avez le droit de ne
pas être satisfait à droite parce qu'on
a trop à gauche parce qu'on a passé et
moi parce que vous n'avez pas tout fait
merci je ne vois pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote nous allons
passer au vote il n'y a pas eu de
demandes de scrutins publics nous allons
donc voté à main levée qui est pour ce
texte
24 24
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
il ya un doute on va faire un assis
debout et pour l'instant il ya égalité
donc kippour
la deux
[Musique]
19 24 26 27 28
moi je vous informe que la fin sur 29
voilà c'est bon parce que certains se
sont enlevées en cours de route qui est
contre
abstention levé la main pour les
abstentions c'est suffisant merci le
texte est donc adopté monsieur ministre
on savait demandé la parole
merci beaucoup madame la présidente très
brièvement pour laisser chacun repartir
chez lui vous dire écoutez je ne sais si
c'est parce que je passe de plus en plus
de temps en votre compagnie et que
j'apprécie de plus en plus votre
compagnie mais je vous trouve
particulièrement dur avec vous même mais
je ne suis pas d'accord avec ce que vous
avez dit madame cohen moi je trouve que
et je voudrais saluer la qualité une
fois encore des débats bah si je suis
désolé maintenant mais je suis désolé
bah je suis désolé sur les intersexe
notamment effectivement débats que nous
avons eus je redis et je salue la
sérénité dans lequel ces débats ont lieu
la qualité va écouter vous permettez moi
de le penser moi j'ai apprécié la
qualité des baies là que nous avons eues
et al'inverse pardon ça doit être ça non
j'en ai mon de comparaison si avec la
première lecture nous avons fait
ensemble et moi je suis désolé je
ressors davantage grandi de ce que j'ai
pu ressortir au savs appelée syndrome de
stockholm ça doit être ça donc je vous
remercie pour les échanges que nous
avons eus et je regrette néanmoins avec
vous et vous me rejoindrez probablement
là dessus effectivement que l'assemblée
ait reculé sur un certain nombre de
points par rapport à l'année dernière
que dans un premier temps effectivement
l'extension à la pma aux femmes seules
aient été rejetées que le prise en
charge par la sécurité sociale de la pma
et été rejetée que la possibilité de
conserver ses gamètes n'ait pas été
adoptée et sur l'article 3 que
le sénat ait décidé d'adopter un double
régime pour la question de l'accès aux
origines là dessus aussi
monsieur le président et ça c'est un
sujet de bioéthique de régimes qui vont
conduire à une égalité entre les enfants
et qui pour certains enfants fera qu'ils
ne pourront pas à leur majorité pouvoir
connaître leurs origines parce que on
aura considéré qu'ils ne sont en réalité
non pas les sujets de droit mais des
objets laissés à la décision de leur
donneur d'une part leur donner accès à
rien et ça je le regrette très
profondément je voulais dit je le redis
ce soir voilà merci une fois encore pour
la qualité de ses débats tout en
regrettant l'issue de ce texte
[Musique]